you're super famous and it would help my
career to be working with you but you
also have a ton of money I'm meeting you
in your mouth mansion and you're asking
me and my little Toyota to come and work
for you for free no
can you make a short film for no money
you can totally make a short film with
no money in this new world of you have
an iPhone in your pocket but also and I
don't think the camera is the most
important thing whatsoever but
you have a phone in your pocket you can
use also I guarantee you you know
somebody who has a more expensive camera
that they are not using that weekend and
will lend it to you bartering is the
best thing in the world if you have
editing skills you know somebody who
wants to make a film say that I will
gladly edit your film for free if you
come and shoot my film when I'm ready to
make my short film if you uh you know
bring your camera I will then do urine
so barter your skills with other people
that's one of the things we have to
offer that we don't need to be paid we
really can our time has value and we can
offer that our skills have value
um but if you wake up film for no money
you have to realize the kind of film you
can make and know with no money you're
not going to be able to make something
that is a knockoff of a big Studio film
you know however if your day job is
doing special effects for a big Studio
film and you have access to all that
equipment and you can use it for free on
the weekend or whatever maybe you can
make something that's crazy impressive
um because you have access to this
equipment that other people who had to
have to pay you know hundreds per hour
to get somebody to do it wouldn't be
able to do
so then have sort of a like-minded
network of people where you can switch
off and do different tasks for each
other and and be open to working on
other people's films too I can't tell
you how many filmmakers want to make a
short film and have never worked on
anyone else's film especially amongst
students and it's like go on somebody
else's set help them out and then learn
what they're doing wrong shorts are
learning experience for everybody see
and then you say oh I'm never going to
do that or you know you go on and work
on a set and you realize ah this is a
big waste of time or they had too many
people I I never forget I met a
filmmaker who made his film at school he
had 50 cast members 50 crew members on
his film and we were like 50. what is
that it's ridiculous it's like we were
at school everyone was willing to help
it's like well I would never use 50
people on my film
um but you know in his case it made
sense for him and it worked for him and
he was happy with it so
who's people have unique situations that
they have advantages and disadvantages
of so you should use the things that you
have advantages of if you want to make
something with no money and if someone's
not in film school where can they sort
of find other filmmakers to just
volunteer to get their feet wet that's
why I think if you work on other
people's film s then you meet people a
right so even if you PA on a film you're
looking and clocking around saying who's
going
to be friendly with and say hey by the
way I'm gonna be making a short film
soon would you be willing to come and do
that also there is you know Craigslist
or mandy.com there's places to also uh
you know like UCL extension has a
website where their students can list
that they're available to work on Films
there's film organizations in Los
Angeles and again I keep on speaking
about Los Angeles because I'm from Los
Angeles but I'm sure in whatever City
you're in there's a Film Society or film
organization the other big tip that I
love is like if you have a film festival
in your city volunteer to work at that
film festival because you're meeting
other people who love film and want to
be involved in film so not only might
you meet people who come into the film
festival but you'll meet other
volunteers who I guarantee you'd be
happy to work on your film because they
too have the same sensibility you have
they want to be making these films they
love films so that's like the number one
tip that I love is like work at a
volunteer at a film festival in your
local Hometown or Film Society and meet
people who have similar interests and
get them to work on your phone how often
do you hear of a short film costing
let's say 70 million dollars well
um
animation Pixar makes these short films
I don't think they're 70 million dollars
but they're done properly through Pixar
you know where nobody's working for free
on those
um so I don't know what the budgets are
for those Pixar shorts but they're not
done for five cents those are expensive
short films also
when you see the films that are
nominated for Academy Award for best
live action it's very rarely us
filmmakers it's usually filmmakers from
other countries because their countries
actually support their filmmakers and
give them money so they can make high
quality films that feel like big old
feature films that just happen to be 12
minutes long through also the academy
loves a short film that's long but you
know like a 25 minute long film that
feels super expensive and like a feature
film is totally and is big and important
and dramatic that's totally Academy
catnip and it's usually made by a
country a filmmaker in a country where
that country gives them money to make
the film so it might not be Millions but
it's well funded and so it's very hard
for a little uh you know us-based
filmmaker where the government won't
give you any money where there's no
grants there's no basically you know
you're either kickstarting to raise some
money or you have wealthy relatives who
are willing to give you money
um or you're paying for it yourself you
know there's always that rule for
feature films like never put your own
money into it but I'm like in shorts
you're putting your own time and your
own money and even if it's not your own
money your own time if you calculated
how much time you're putting into this
that you could be spending earning money
for that hours it's like that's
thousands upon thousands of dollars that
you've contributed
and in some ways it might be best to put
your own money whether you're paying
from your waiting tables job or whatever
it is because you're going to learn
lessons faster and you can control it
you know I the phase I always use is you
are the studio when you're making a
short film you are like a studio and
then you get to decide what you want a
green light and invest in and you have
to take it all the way from
commissioning the script to releasing it
out into the world so you know some
studios can get away with like they
don't have any money and they're going
to do it totally cheap but um you know
like there's a lot of famous actors that
make short films or like screenwriters
those people have money and so you can't
expect people to work for free for it
and people aren't expecting the films
that they make to be shot on an iPhone
you know super Cheapo kind of thing when
you see a famous actor who's directed a
short film those are properly funded and
again they got money to burn I'm sure
they put their own money into it and
they don't do it for you know two cents
on the iPhone
and they shouldn't you know that's not
what people are expecting from them and
you know if somebody famous were to ask
me to work on their phone for free I'd
be like no I mean I love it I would
obviously love to work with you you're
super famous and it would help my career
to be working with you but you also have
a ton of money I'm meeting you in your
mouth mansion and you're asking me and
my little Toyota to come and work for
you for free no
that's actually a film idea
you're pulling up to the gate the car
stalls movie starts yes
great should a filmmaker expect to make
money from their short film
so the thing about short films is
there's really no money in short films
what you're investing in is you're
launching yourself as a filmmaker and
that film will hopefully get you other
will launch you as a filmmaker and
hopefully get you other work so you need
to think of it as an investment in
yourself and that's where the calling
card kind of aspect happens that like
I've created this to show you this is
what my talent is and therefore
hopefully you will hire me and pay me
money to move on to do the next thing so
even though they didn't give you cash
like here's 20 million dollars for your
short film
um they actually gave you 20 million
dollars to write a feature or something
of that sort
um you uh so you can make money that way
it's it's by launching yourself but
actual shorts themselves sometimes do
make money there are still a few places
that will pay for license a short film
the problem is
so it used to be called interstitial uh
uh programming where movie channels like
used to have a feature that runs short
and they need to put something else on
before the hour starts up again and
that's the short films I made for Fox
were for a cable channel that used them
that way you had 20 minutes you had to
pad and so let's put some short films in
there and that way we patted the time
HBO used to pay money for short films to
use it in that way but now people all
they do is they do they'd rather make a
little featurette about a TV show to
convince you to watch that TV show and
fill up the time that way so
domestically there there isn't a market
so much for it anymore but PBS still
occasionally pays for short films caps
and when I say pay for they're licensing
it they're licensing a short film to air
in a certain way in a certain market for
a certain time they're not buying it out
right there are some markets foreign
that also still pay for films sometimes
to be used on TV interstitially
sometimes to be used in other ways
Airlines sometimes sure films you know
it used to be too like oh my short film
is going to be on iTunes or Amazon and
people are going to pay me for that
um and there some are sorry the Academy
Award shorts by the way are their own
category but those actually get put in
movie theaters and people pay money to
see the Academy Award nominated show
films which makes me so happy sorry
which makes me so happy and that's for
features and they put the animated
shorts out that way they put the feature
the the live action shorts out that way
and the documentary and people pay money
to see them in theater and it's like it
proves people are interested they want
to see these films that the academy has
said are worthy and of value
um and those films do make money for the
filmmakers uh so there are case like
weird ways that sometimes films do make
money and make their money back
um but oh that's a unicorn you know most
times you just got to go in the
understanding of sorry the other way you
can earn money is a festival sometimes
there's money prizes at festivals so I
know of many filmmakers who've made one
more as Festival prizes than they
actually put into making their film so
they made profit that way from the
festival prizes so you know another
reason to do festivals is there is a
category for short films and you can be
a prize winner that way
um so sometimes there are ways to make
money the funny thing too is like later
on if you become famous uh you know
we're very interested in famous people
short films so they might be interested
in your film that way once you become
famous or maybe really luck out and
somebody starring in your film it
becomes famous later on and then there's
interested in so but what would stop you
from making money from your short film
is if you didn't do everything right if
you didn't get all the cast sign release
forms giving you the rights to their
performances if you didn't do deal memos
so that said they're afraid that some
crew member will come back and sue you
when all of a sudden you're making money
if you have music in it or not even
music but artwork or clips of other
films
that you don't have the rights to that
at a time you're like ah what the hell
it serves my artistic vision and it
makes it great
um but somebody's saying hey I can give
you money but you have to have all these
things cleared you have to buy errors in
admission insurance which stops people
from suing you it doesn't stop people
from pursuing it protects people when
they're being sued and you have that
costs money too so there's a lot of
sometimes and then there's sag payments
that change when you actually sell your
film so there's sometimes uh there's
other reasons why you can't sell your
film even if somebody were to offer you
for the money for the film but sometimes
it's also laughable it's like hey
somebody in Poland wants to license your
film for 13 it's like is it worth
everybody's headache to do all that
paperwork to get your film license for
thirteen dollars and and is it also two
let's say like Brands like if you yeah
if you have like in the same way forever
again if you're trying to learn how to
do it right for the feature film you
should do all that right for the short
film so that you don't have issues but
you know it's like if somebody in your
short film is drinking Coca-Cola but
they're not like a murderer or something
like that they're just accidentally
drinking Coca-Cola nobody's gonna stop
your film being distributed being like
you didn't clear the rights for
Coca-Cola it's not that big of a deal it
would be more if you know the Killer
Clown kills everybody with a Coca-Cola
can then there could be an issue it's
like Coca-Cola would not approve of that
use of their can in that way what if
it's uh you have a scene where there's
like a couple at the table and there's a
replica of a Renoir in the background
right is that someone still needs to
clear the rights for that yeah they do
definitely
that's always kind of surprising another
thing I'd heard about recently that I
never even thought about was tattoos
that the tattoo artist has created
original artwork so if it's the real
tattoo and you're using it in a very
obvious way in the film it isn't just
like they're walking and they happen to
have tattoos down their arms but there's
a big part of the film that it focuses
on this tattoo you have to get that
cleared from the tattoo artist who
created that is original artwork wow yes
that that's new and sort of a new well
you to me it was explained to me and I
was like I never thought about tattoos
okay but that is original artwork too
well you can get temporary ones exactly
yeah whoever designed that temperature
to get them to sign to say that they
gave you permission to use their artwork
for wow I know crazy isn't it wow that's
fascinating to know that again everybody
you know is creating something uh
artistically so you know what I always
say documentary there's a lot more lean
way because they're capturing real life
but for narrative filmmakers the
argument is you're creating a fictional
World in which you've touched everything
in that and have decided everything's in
there for a reason
so if you've chosen to have this Renoir
in the background then there's a reason
that you've done that and then you
should appropriately pay everybody if
not take the Renoir out get a clear door
worker just go in the back and scribble
it yourself and put something else in
there because you've chosen all of that
sure sure yeah just a couple brush
strokes and just pretend it's some kind
of moderate there you go it's done
cooking is what they call it when you
put like tape over something so it looks
different or changes it out something or
you know we often say um because you
often have crew members be your uh Cass
and be your extras or whatever you just
really want to watch their clothes
because often crew members are wearing
like a Panna Vision t-shirt I'm like
could you turn your t-shirt inside out
could you take oh um Major League
Baseball or any kind of Major League
major sports thing they all want money
so you don't want somebody with a
Yankees cap or you don't want somebody
with an NFL branded Dodgers whatever you
know all that is protected and you can't
do and again I'm based in Los Angeles so
I will of course say Dodgers or whatever
but the Hollywood sign is also something
that's protected and so you have to pay
for the use to use the Hollywood sign
and you can't just be like who's in the
background it's like we'll pick a
different shot so it's not in the
background but they want money they know
about it and they also actively screen
to look for it if you've used it and
they will come after you